hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen hierzu einen neuen
einen neuen motor wie ok zu einer neuen
mode review hier auf meinem kanal und
zwar von der dauernd pickup modification
die extrem simpel ist eine extrem kleine
modifikation aber die etwas hinzufügt
was ich glaube ich jeder minecraft
irgendwie schon mal gewünscht hat
erstmals schuldigen dass ich hier so ein
bisschen verrannt aussehe
ich habe relativ wenig geschlafen muss
jetzt zu produzieren weil ich jetzt
wegen meinem studium wohin fahren muss
und alles mögliche so ein paar komische
sachen machen
jedenfalls würde ich sagen ich fange
euch direkt an und zeigt euch die
modifikation indem ich euch je das
crafting rezept zeige und zwar wird
dieses exclusive eier legte ex klub von
pick up das wird nicht so geklappt hat
es wird so betrachtet man hat hier drei
eisenwaren und rechts drei eisenwaren
man oben ein glas in der mitte eine
änderten oder darunter ein red stage und
dadurch dass seine ender perle im
redstone könnte man denken oder das
ganze ding auch so ein bisschen saison
game boy das hat etwas mit technik zu
tun ja das hat es auch im inventar mir
das ganze auf einer zweiten seite wer
kann mir hier gehen dauernd pickup dass
die modifikation und es ist einfach nur
ein item hinzugefügt worden
dieses item ist allerdings extrem cool
und hat sehr sehr viel macht wir können
beispielsweise einfach mal rechtsweg
damit machen wir mit links kann
mitmachen passiert mixa kann zumal
sachen auf zerstöre ich kann damit
einfach mal rechts weg machen dann sehen
wir hier schon ein bisschen so aus wie
creator haben hierzu leistet items da
ist noch nichts irgendwie drin und wir
haben auch hier wenn ich hier so durch
kohle da ist noch nichts ich nehme jetzt
erst mal ganz kurz hier noch so ein erde
blog einfach mal wenn ich das mal ganz
gut zeigen kann
ich gehe wieder auf direkt schule feiern
mit rechtsklick und dann seht ihr schon
hier oben einen kompass sie dir zu hause
dieses creative inventar was ganz zu
anfang weil in diesem creative motto
hinzugefügt wurde wo es doch nicht diese
ganzen kategorien also ich kann das
ganze auch natürlich verwenden wenn ich
im gaylord 0 bin vielleicht ist man
besser ich das dann zu zeigen und zwar
jetzt hab ich halt eigentlich kein
creative inventar wenn ich jetzt mal er
drücke seht ich hab ein ganz normales in
den tag wenn ich allerdings diesen
exclusive eier was will dieses münchen
von mir alter steht das schon die ganze
zeit hier
wir hatten ja schon mal so ein paar
komische problemchen mit hühnern in der
halloween folge rollo kleine türen wohl
gut dann macht das hühnchen jetzt
einfach mal mit endlos mit diesem da
hinten ist auch wieder so ein hühnchen
naja jedenfalls egal wir jedenfalls ich
bin offen und man merkt selbst total
verpennt
das hat man auch an meiner stimme ich
mache jetzt einfach mal rechtsklick da
hinten brennt
irgendwas ist mir scheißegal ich mache
jetzt erstmal rechtsklick mit dem
exclusive eier und wir sind dann hier in
diesem creative menü das gute hier dran
ist allerdings das ist jetzt nicht
irgendwie schiiten im game zu null so
eine modifikation sondern ich kann jetzt
einfach mal auf erde drauf klicken und
alles das hier so gelb wenn ich jetzt
wieder auf den exklusiv eier drauf
drückt ihr seht ihr da ist er drin wenn
ich wieder hier draufklicken der iss die
erde wieder weg ich kann auch einfach
die erde nehmen die ich vorhin abgebaut
habt ihr gesehen habt also im creative
mir ins emmental geholt habe kann ich
die hände nehmen und einfach mal hier
rein legen beispielsweise dann habe ich
die erde noch und hier drin ist das geld
jetzt denkt euch erstmal was bringt das
überhaupt ich kann ja auch ich glaub
machen ein kleines kreuzchen
das ganze ist extrem cool und zwar
können mich jetzt einfach mal
beispielsweise was können wir noch
anklicken
ich klicke mal noch eichenholz an und
sieht könnte ich auch mal anklicken und
wenn ich dies nicht finde kann ich oben
eingeben
samen nie heißt es dass sie zusammen ich
weiß gar nicht wie heißen denn diese
kleinen entlassen zu haben oder als die
kerne das ist halt das blöde an dem
inventar muss man also ein bisschen
durchscrollen acht es sind weizenkörner
okay dann kann ich theoretische oben
weizenkörner eingeben dann kann ich
immer auf weizenkörner allerdings geht
machen jetzt gehe ich wieder zum
exklusiv und sehe die erde eichenholz
und weizenkörner das gute ist jetzt wenn
ich jetzt beispielsweise nämlich hier
mal locker bauer der eigentlich als
werde mein inventar kommen würde
da laufe ich hier drüber dann erkennt
der extruder feier wenn ich ihn im
inventar ab wenn ich ihn rausschmeißen
sammelt dass die erde auf wenn ich jetzt
wieder richtig mache sind die sachen
hier wieder drin
er kennt diese exklusive okay das ist
ein blog den hast du im extruder feuer
drin den willst du nicht einsammeln das
heißt das ist extrem gut dafür wenn man
irgendwie im underground oder in
irgendeiner höhle irgendwelche mops
töten will
weil da ist es bei mir mal so ich gehe
in eine höhle box alles kaputt dann habe
ich keinen platz mehr verreisen weil ich
ganz viel knochen und ganz viel spinnen
weben und ganz viel seide von
spinnen im inventar hat und ganz viel
verrottetes fleisch und das will ich
eigentlich gar nicht alles haben dann
nimmt man einfach so traf man sich 60
jahr feier der hat jetzt echt nicht
teuer ist es gibt auch noch ein
billigeres crafting rezept das muss man
in den einstellungen aktivieren aber das
möchte ich auch nicht zeigen weil ich
nicht will dass das ganze so wild
münchen mit erde oder irgendwas man es
kommt da sind jetzt übrigens auf
tradierte weggeschmissen aber kann sie
nicht wieder aufsammeln weil ich das
hier im extruder feuer drin das gleiche
gilt jetzt auch wenn ich hier irgendwie
mal samen beispielsweise ab wann kommt
denn jetzt endlich mal da kommt jetzt
beispielsweise seeds raus kann ich jetzt
auch nicht aus sammeln das ist
beispielsweise so wenn ihr denkt ich
habe schon riesige fahren aber ich will
jetzt einfach mal erde abfahren hier so
ein bisschen und dann kommen aber ganz
viel weizen draußen die wollte ich die
ganze weizen haben dann könnt ihr das
einfach so machen es jetzt als grad kurz
geruckelt ihr könnt allerdings auch hier
dieses dings die damals mit eichenholz
kann jeder seiner reden zeigt also es
funktioniert wirklich mit jedem block
hier ist beispielsweise jetzt mal
eichenholz wenn ich dieses eichenholz
abfall dann bleibt es einfach da liegen
das gute an dem ex kunde fall ist
allerdings auch wir können
beziehungsweise dem beta update
hinzugefügt ist der download link ist
wie immer unten in der beschreibung wir
können da jetzt rechts drauf machen dann
haben wir hier kleine kreuzchen vor
das heißt es jetzt ein kleines kreuz
bereichen holz und bei weizen können und
bereiten können dann nämlich mal raus
und jetzt wenn ich da so ein blog
rumliegen sich laufe der zeit da wird er
direkt gelöscht mit seinem kleinen feuer
dingsbums das heißt wenn ich
beispielsweise in einer höhle will und
ich fahre ganz viel oder kommt ganz viel
verrottetes fleisch oder wenn ihr noch
viel besser in mons monster falle
abnehmer farben her kommen die ganzen
items runter gespielt da sind coole
sachen dabei wie irgendwie pfeile von
skeletten allerdings habt ihr gar kein
bock auf knochen dann nehmt ihr euch
einfach den euro exklusiv feier geht
hier oben drauf gibt hier knochen ein
beispielsweise nicht mal einen knochen
aktiviert den und packt ihr so ein
kleines kreuz in ran weil jeder knochen
jetzt feuchte drop wird verschwindet
automatisch werden hier vorne auch noch
erde
die wird jetzt auf alles einfach
gelöscht allerdings habe ich jetzt bei
weizen ja extra habe ich das kreuz hier
nicht hin gemacht das heißt wenn ich zu
weizen hingehe und ich dass eventuell
später nummer einsammeln möchte dann
bleibt es natürlich liegen
das ganze bleibt jetzt allerdings
natürlich nicht ewig liegen also das ist
jetzt nicht irgendwie so mäßig in eurem
inventar wird nicht angezeigt sondern es
liegt wirklich auf den boden wie
irgendein altem was da liegt ich aber
dinge ich allerdings nicht einsammeln
die spot nach ein paar minuten das war's
eigentlich schon mit der modifikation
ich wollte euch diese modifikation
einfach zeigen weil ich die gesehen bei
einem amerikanischen youtube und das ist
etwas was ich in hero oft gesagt habe
als ich da vor dem mob fall gespannt und
gesagt weil er mit der ganzen scheiße
hier was soll ich damit den ganzen ortes
im fleisch immer weggeschmissen lava
müll einmal gemacht und so einfach ein
extrem feier machen im inventar
mitnehmen der verband jetzt hat echt
kein platz beziehungsweise er verbraucht
viel weniger platz als wenn ihr nicht
tötet und alles voll jetzt mit knochen
und verarbeitetem fleisch in der höhe
und alles mögliche hat diese
modifikation runterladen ist extrem
simpel zu installieren und es ist auch
eine extrem simple modifikation das
einzige was ihr wissen müsst habe ich
euch gesagt es ist eine 1.70 fifa zion
und läuft mit fortschreiten ladet euch
fortschritt doppelklick baufortschrittes
forge installieren da zieht diese
modifikation einfach in den mods ordner
und das war's dann auch schon mit der
heutigen vorstellung ich hoffe euch hat
es gefallen und ich konnte euch mit
dieser modifikation unterhalten auch
wenn meine stimme ein bisschen im arsch
ist und ich ein bisschen marge bin und
es kann irgendwie acht uhr morgens ist
oder so aber wenn es euch gefallen hat
würde mich über eine bewertung freund
schreibt mir weitere modifikationen
kommentare vielleicht nicht solche ganz
umfangreiche modifikationen aber kleine
simple modifikationen wie das hier was
einfach coole sachen hinzufügen aber
relativ simpel sind es gibt ja die zitat
simplicity skripte witti und ich weiß
gar nicht ob wieder total schnell
geredet und wahrscheinlich extrem nicht
geschnitten in diesem video aber egal